to make this even crazier uh there are
more female hosts than there are men
hosts and by average they're managing
higher valued properties yet they're
still making 25 less so and by volume
women there are more women hosts for
Airbnb right yeah so there's more that's
listed I think there's like it's like
almost half but then women are like 54
and then men are like 46. they just suck
at business
oh
[Music]
all right this one's fun because I'm
gonna see if you guys can figure this
out female Airbnb hosts
earn about 25 less than male Airbnb
hosts it's because they're so lazy
Jesus Christ there goes audience
and that's how you alienate the whole
audience just kidding just kidding just
no no yeah it's uh there are a lot of
reasons but I want to see what you guys
think they are honestly maybe they're
not as comfortable taking on certain
clientele that they might not be able to
manage themselves or have some sort of
security issue with or feel fearful I
wasn't even thinking about the ones that
rent out a room
mm-hmm hey that's a good that's that
you're on the right track because I was
like I don't even know any of the hosts
I've ever rented from that's true so I
was like wait how did they how are they
how do they lower 25 they must suck by
the way so then I asked oh they're not
asking for it they're not asking you
know they're not asking there's got to
be the room in thing for sure to make
this even crazier uh there are more
female hosts than there are men hosts
and by average they're managing higher
value properties yet they're still
making 25 less is it because the is it
because uh what are they doing wrong so
and by volume women there are more women
hosts for Airbnb right yeah so there's
more that's listed I think there's like
it's like almost half but then women are
like 54 and then men are like 46. they
just suck at business
this is what are these Airbnb women are
they owned with their husbands but it's
under their name could be because I
think that's all because I you know I've
talked enough Airbnb people most of them
I've seen it are men I don't see that
many women if you're telling me there's
more women I through the last three
years I don't see that many women I see
a lot of men
is it maybe because the male the men
have multiple properties so the way that
they're earning is so these are these
are just the hosts and these are the
this is the income that the host account
is bringing in so it's it's almost
irrelevant whether or not they're the
owner of the property these are the
hosts representing the property that's
right oh so who knows who owns it but
because they they also show yeah they
also if they're hosts they could be
Leasing and having an arrangement with
the owner there's all these different
tricks that they can do it's just down
to like the stats on Airbnb itself women
are making 25 Less in terms of their God
yeah that that that blows my mind
because it makes sense if there was less
women on Airbnb as hosts but if they're
if there's more and they're making less
and the properties they own are more
expensive yeah so they could charge more
so I don't know so you you actually did
say it they don't really know the whole
exact reason but they do know one thing
that that's conclusive is that women
price their listings lower wait but you
just said that they have more expense
they do so they're not charging it the
right way they're pricing it lower than
they could be so they love giving
discounts isn't that a smart way of
saying they're dumb
no I think I think
I think Society itself has uh created
like uh a range already what women make
and because of that psychologically
they're charging less because like okay
yeah this is how much you know like
think about WNBA right because this is
how much WNBA makes this how women
soccer make this is how female Airbnb
people should make you think this is
like subconsciously societally really I
think it's wow for me just I when I see
how uh ladies would price things yeah
they actually don't try to maximize and
to see what the market will take they
they're so considerate of people that
they try to find a fair range and I
think most guys would just try to
[ __ ] charge the most aggressive
they're aggressive right and then if it
doesn't sell then they go oh maybe I
gotta drop it down a notch but I think
just like how I've seen women advertise
or just other uh when they're creating
their own eBay or whatever just from my
experience when they price it out
they're so considerate about the buyer
that they try to find a fair range
already so they're creating a discount
already okay and that's that's just
anecdotal no yeah no I think what you
said what you said is actually very
accurate because they don't they still
can't really 100 tell but one of the
assumptions within the study is that
they believe women technically or um
tend to Value the relationship with the
customer more than the payment so dude I
must be a woman then because every time
you hit Jill enter into anything that we
can't negotiate right I'll be like hey I
think we should just get it so did you
even negotiate I'm like no they said
they'll have one left and then she's
like no like what's the worst gonna have
if you negotiate they'll say no again no
no no it's gonna ruin the whole
relationship yeah I'm with you on that
yeah but then my wife is like way more
hardcore like no she's just more of a
dude than yours she's just more Easter
they said there's only two left
they're saving this one for me didn't
you just hear him he said my friend all
right like we're friends now yeah that's
so what you said really is what kind of
where their assumption lies is that
women tend to just uh gravitate towards
a different value system than men when
pricing these things now I think guys
are more dumb they're like I think I
could get 50 bucks for this thing really
just try 60. all right and then they'll
they'll they'll go high as possible and
then they're like no one's buying it all
right maybe we should do 50. all right
how about 55. all right
so wild dude I feel more comfortable if
it's a female host I feel more
comfortable because I feel like they're
cleaner and they'll take care of it yes
I'm always like yeah I want like a
female host it's cleaner more meticulous
the more nurturing problem yeah there's
candles are they is that stat and I'm
sure maybe there's no info on this but
is that like they're making 25 less or
whatever per transaction or are we
talking like as a whole so so they're
not necessarily even getting more
business for less money it's like just
in general Less in general but they also
but he also mentioned that they're
charging less when they could charge
more more undervalued to the property
they're managing that's what I'm about
to have like so let's say they are
charging a lot but because the houses
are so expensive it's like it's killing
the ratio you're making it smaller yeah
exactly yeah so they could be you know
getting more money but they're choosing
a different angle in which to sell and
have a I guess a relationship
also a blanket statement there's no way
we could we can't like
sum this up without doing these like
gentle slam dunks
because here's a slant gentle slam dunk
because you know like the boys and girls
argument
it starts in [ __ ] kindergarten of
who's better and we never let it go yeah
[ __ ] Tags I'm stuck it on your ass
and I'm 38.
and the interesting thing is this
conversation or this like study is you
know kind of it's pre-dating like any
there's not like women were complaining
about this prior they weren't they are
now yeah
have you seen the new Airbnb stats yeah
you know what I mean it's like but
you're the one pricing it that way like
we the man has nothing to do with it
it's like clearly a bunch of dudes put
the study together to be like we gotta
beat him to the punch man
a guy or a girl I'll probably keep my
mouth shut if I was a guy like let me
give it let them under charge a little
overcharge I'm trying to find a name
what I'm thinking is that if they did it
at a discount what if they're wouldn't
their volumes be higher in rent like
wouldn't they be booked out more
throughout the year so that's what I'm
saying what if they make more in in
conjunction with the same sentiment that
I'm sharing where it's like I would
again blanket saving but like if it's a
chick who's hosting I'm like maybe the
spot is like cleaner you know what I
mean
um so I would I rather choose yeah I'd
rather book from a girl too man I know
the book from a girl it's gonna be
cheaper yeah yeah exactly exactly what's
your name Janet all right now they're
going to unionize after this video
because all female Airbnb hosts watch JK
news and they're all going to unionize
they should charge more no yeah girls
just charge 25 more yeah there's also
the unknown stat if uh so like expenses
in your stay right some Airbnb places
you'll be paying more for little things
if you don't clean it a certain way you
pay it fine they don't know yet if like
maybe when men do their listing like
you're just paying for everything all
like the add-ons rather than them
cleaning it's like you clean it and or
you pay this or maybe their men are more
aggressive with collecting fines from
[ __ ] you do wrong who knows dude Airbnb
does have sneaky little charges though
because I'll be like 50 a night great
and then it's like total of four hundred
thousand dollars like what the [ __ ] is
this especially after covet cleaning fee
six grand they get you on the board
games like if there's missing pieces you
get the email later on like we're
missing the we're missing this that's
Pawn in the chessboard like oh no yeah
they do they try to remember you find it
in your kid's pocket and [ __ ] you're
like God
damn 50 dude I wonder if they did like a
cross reference like study on chick Uber
drivers so if it's girl Uber drivers
right and they're all driving Mercedes
and they're still making less than
chicks are just dumb
industry man can you imagine that's the
something this just in chicks are just
dumb
and then they need to cross fronts a
bunch of Industries and see if they're
calling out the right price yeah so the
average nightly rate of a female host in
like comparison to a male host thirty
dollars Less on average
[Music]
but we already do we already said that
we do anyways what about the the
statistics for escorts male versus
female that's true oh dude are you
kidding there's a bit like you got to
take into account that most male escorts
are working for other males
so they get more money tend to have a
more robust sexual appetite
robust robust dance it's kind of hot
it's solid I know I'm turned on yeah
that that just brings to mind because I
was just in Amsterdam and I was asking
my friend we were going through the red
light district and you know what all the
girls are and then I was like and she
was telling me hey you know there's a
there's a men's District too with like
Gigolos for like women wow I'm so glad I
never been down that street yeah and
then she goes you might be inspired dude
Men's Health Magazine guy and then I
asked her I was like is there like a a
men's uh area for other men and she goes
yeah it's the same district yeah oh wow
makes sense yeah makes sense to be
honest I'm just glad I've never been
down that street do they stand in the
glass windows too the guys yeah yeah
they're like come on
I'm like oh [ __ ] they don't need to I've
never seen it yeah there's a guy section
yeah where was it like across the river
drill I don't think any of us go there
looking for the guy section you can walk
to it from where I thought I went
through every corner it's further away
and then it becomes also it's like a
whole new section Joe is actively
looking yeah I was yeah dude I'm the
kind of guy that goes to like Target and
does every single aisle to see what's
there and then I decide what to buy
that's like a four hour Excursion that's
pretty long it's like [ __ ] Disneyland
yeah Target's that's terrible that's
just how I shot bro
that's why I can't shop I gotta go to
Amazon
[Music]